alors justement jean
tu as décidé de rembourser
les
voilà des derniers dons à plusieurs
parties en difficulté financièrement
après le premier tour notamment le ps
les républicains et europe ecologie les
verts c'est beau
c'est à dire nous étions à la réunion de
la petite équipe de campagne et
quand même vous êtes combien de notre
île le chef détective je dois je dire
l'équipe
s'est pas mal et ils sont tous très
brillant et tout d'un coup il y en a un
qu'il y tient et à la dame du mali déjà
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui fait un appel d'offres pour ces
derniers est quelqu'un dit je crois que
c'est un de mes enfants oui mais on ne
veut lui donner un coup de main et
j'ai dit oui mais j'avais le trésorier
juste à côté
de la caisse non justement j'ai un peu
de valeur je me suis fait rembourser
alors que lui-même n'a passé à moins de
moins de 50 ans fait
une dotation de l'état dont avait
bénéficié la dernière fois il en a eu
puis ça met l'eau à tous les canadiens
préfèrent le premier tome est là dessus
je vais pour faire la campagne tout ça
la vérité c'est ce que je suis la
prochaine fois je convoque
tous été des années 800 me
alors pour revenir donc mon offre moi
quand j'entends quelqu'un sur le point
de se noyer bon jeu mais il faut réagir
maintenant ça non mais j'avais pas les
moyens de lui envoyer un canot à moteur
je lui ai envoyé
donc l'ania fait grincer les dents le
voyage
est gelée envoyé à tous les toits il dit
à derrière merci un geste un petit peu à
quoi je devrais dire qui et qui est un
peu que je voulais chouette montré que
les candidats au fort c'est pas les gens
pas la guerre
chacun défend son bout de gras chacun
essaye de défendre ses idées s'il n'y a
pas de griefs entre le nom précis voilà
quelques-uns c'est qu'il candidats que
tu aimes le moins toi
tu dois aller en vacances celui avec qui
je me battais à 20,15 avec les kings
s'il y en a peut être qui je parlerai
pas beaucoup critiquent parce que je
sais pas avec qui de quoi je parle et
oui même si je le dis tu peux en tirer
une déduction pour la finale parce que
ta vie alors on sait que c'est un bond à
ma fille
m
non non
tu vas tu rigoles ans donc je ne les ai
pas dit non tu n'as pas mais je ne veux
pas non plus que l'on bull est ce que tu
sais que emmanuel macron voulait ramener
à punta cana
et
se changer de couleur quoi
par honnêteté et compte tenu notamment
des yes je suis un peu obligé de te
répondre la mention j'ai répondu de
mieux que j'ai pu sané quel était mon
choix